Hey everyone, Michael here,
have you paid even the slightest bit of attention to weird things,
your uncle post on Facebook,
you might've noticed a hip boogeyman in the conspiracy theory world, bill Gates,
the Microsoft founder,
and second richest person alive has joined the ranks of the Rockefeller family,
George Soros, the Bilderberg group,
and the Illuminati on the list of shadowy figures.
People would like to blame their problems on and as it currently concerns
William Henry Gates. The third, that problem is COVID 19.
Now theories about Gates involvement in the Corona virus pandemic come in,
all shapes and sizes ranging from so bizarre.
We can't even trace their connection to reality, to actual facts,
grossly distorted,
to seem scarier rumors include bill Gates owns the patent for SARS cov to the
virus that causes COVID-19. He does not.
Bill Gates will use a forthcoming vaccine, do secretly implant microchips in us.
He won't.
And bill Gates is trying to build a global surveillance state as foretold in the
biblical book of revelation, also false, but in a much more complicated way.
But what I find interesting about the people behind these theories,
those who posit a shadowy nefarious character,
that secretly controls the world with their wealth and influence.
It's how they often overlook the real and scary truth.
That's out in broad daylight.
And the theory swirling around bill Gates are no exception.
Let's find out in this wisecrack edition on the truth about bill Gates.
Before we get into it,
this video is sponsored by our patrons and if supporting a wisecrack or not
sitting through more ads appeals to you consider becoming one by clicking right
up here for ad free access patriarch support.
It helps us continue our mission of entertaining and informing the world
regardless of fluctuations in ad revenue or the YouTube algorithms sign up now
at patrion.com/wisecrack or stick around till the end of the video,
to hear more now to preempt a lot of angry comments.
Bill Gates is not only currently the second richest man on earth.
He's also one of the single most generous people on the planet in terms of the
total money given away over the last 25 years, bill and his wife,
Melinda have given over $50 billion to charity,
much of it through the eponymous bill and Melinda Gates foundation.
What's more Gates has pledged to donate the majority of his $100 billion estate.
And upon his death,
his three children will each receive a $10 million inheritance totaling,
approximately one 33rd of 1% of his total net worth for
scale.
That's like if your parents had a million dollars and left you 300 bucks to
understand how conspiracy theories often distract us from the very public,
not at all secret bullets, powerful people.
Let's take a look at one of the most prominent bill Gates,
conspiracy theories that he is somehow going to make the entire human population
get the Corona virus vaccine,
a disease he purportedly invented in order to microchip us all for again,
some vague plot to track our walks of shame to the waffle house.
This theory falls into the category of cherry picking a few facts to tell a
narrative with only the loosest relationship to reality.
And that reality is a thing called ID 2020.
ID 2020 is a nonprofit organization loosely affiliated with the bill Gates
extended universe.
While the organization doesn't list the Gates foundation as a partner,
it does list Microsoft,
a company that Gates only recently resigned from the board of and Gavi,
a vaccine advocacy organization that received substantial funding from the Gates
foundation ID 2020. His pitch is pretty simple.
A legal identity is increasingly a gateway to participate in the modern world.
And lots of people can't actually identify themselves if you're homeless in
America.
And can't prove who you are with a driver's license or social security card,
getting a job social services, or just participating in society is complicated.
If you're living on skid row,
holding on to identification in the face of rainstorms police seizures and theft
is just really hard. Now imagine those same problems, but faced by refugees,
looking for healthcare or people in the developing world,
looking to get a small business loan ID.
2020 wants to fix that with a digital identity system.
It's on the cloud. Now.
Even though bill Gates is not seeming to be directly involved with ID 2020,
he has addressed similar issues surrounding identification,
and here's where the theory start. As it turns out,
the medical records are super important. A constant problem.
Healthcare workers face than developing world is wondering for instance,
who has,
and hasn't been inoculated against polio or measles and the Gates foundation,
since it would like to stop children from dying and preventable diseases,
partially funded research into an infrared tattoo,
a quantum dot that could provide a medical record that can't get destroyed in a
flood or lost under a floorboard.
People living in the developed world might take for granted how important
medical records are,
but every time a doctor makes sure you're unscheduled for your shots or check
your own allergies, they need reliable medical records, quantum dot tattoos,
or otherwise it's fair to suppose that Gates believes identification is a key
hurdle in giving people medical care,
but you can probably already see how this quickly turns into fodder for
conspiracy theorist ID 2020 quantum dots and vaccines got amalgamated into a
scary theory about how Gates was trying to microchip and track people and some
expansive global surveillance system to be perfectly clear.
Bill Gates is not demonically marking. People are calling the population,
but here's the troubling thing.
Plenty of what he actually does funds and believes is ethically debatable at
best and downright harmful at worst.
And this is what makes the conspiracy theories about him.
So frustrating to figure out why I want to talk to you about disease
eradication. If you watch the decoding bill Gates documentary on Netflix,
you might've learned about how the man has committed to valiantly defeating.
Polio and malaria. You know, this was this big,
risky thing we were doing to help lead polio eradication.
Just a quick definition before we move on to.
Eradicate a disease means to bring cases of the disease to zero everywhere
forever. Meaning.
Unlike Mel Gibson's career, it's never coming back. Smallpox for instance,
was declared eradicated in 1980 after a global vaccination campaign.
And while there's a few lab samples left,
hasn't been naturally transmitted since then. There's malaria and polio.
These diseases suck. Malaria kills hundreds of thousands of people a year.
And before a global campaign against polio,
hundreds of thousands of people were left paralyzed from the virus. And here,
I want to say that I personally believe that a bill Gates is a smart man who
genuinely believes he's helping the world and B he might nevertheless be hurting
science and global health policy to show.
I want to introduce you to Dr. Errata coaching,
who was pretty much the Bobby Knight of public health coachee by all accounts is
kind of a Dick, but he's a Dick with a good track record.
He ran an extremely successful campaign against tuberculosis for the who before
leading their charge against malaria. In 2006,
coachee had a pension for firing people as well as angry and pharmaceutical
companies and the nonprofits he worked for,
obviously among those nonprofits was the Gates foundation,
which had made malaria eradication a priority in 2007.
Now Earl radicating malaria is a really hard stopping smallpox,
still no small feat.
Was it at least easier because the virus can only be spread by humans.
So to track down every last case, you only need to track down people.
The parasite that causes malaria is a little harder to track.
It's been part of its life in mosquitoes and part of it in humans.
So when the Gates foundation announced,
they were going to funnel money into eradicating malaria,
that is wiping it off the face of the earth.
Most public health experts thought it was a bad idea.
It was neither feasible nor safe as Sonia Shaw writes in her book,
pandemic rather experts, including cocci.
He felt that containing the disease was a better use of resources.
In other words, we could spend the money on drugs, mosquito nets, insecticides,
and other measures to drastically reduce cases rather than expending endless
resources, trying to bring them to zero.
I missed the call from malaria eradication coachee in a memo leaked to the New
York times,
complained to his boss that the Gates foundation was having a corrosive effect
on the scientific process.
He warned that the influence of the foundation on global health policy had
dangerous consequences on the policy-making process and world health and accused
the foundation of only promoting policies that have been researched by its own
grantees. In one case,
cocci accused the Gates foundation of pushing a potentially dangerous malaria
drug, a policy that just so happened to be funded by their own research dollars.
Dr. Cocci wrote,
although it was less and less straightforward that the health agency should
recommend it.
The agency's objections were met with intense and aggressive opposition from
Gates back scientists and the foundation,
the who he wrote needs to stand up to such pressures and ensure that the review
of evidence it a rigorously independent invested interest did not happen.
Instead. The who adopted the Gates back to plan another health expert.
I'm your Otter.
Ron said his experience with Gates finance policy groups convinced him they were
engaged in stomach churning group thing.
And what happened to coachee for speaking out about Gates as shy rights he was
put on gardening leave, never to be heard from again.
And this is the nonsense all secret truth about bill Gates.
He's not a secret dictator with a shadowy agenda. Instead,
he's a very rich person who can throw his money around to have his voice heard
those contributions to the who he's also buying influence over their policies.
He's no different in that way. From Michael Bloomberg,
who in his bid for New York city mayor famously made charitable donations to
groups that were critical of him to shut them up,
or the Koch brothers who have spent millions of dollars advancing their pet
political causes or George Soros who has done.
Similarly on the opposite side of the political spectrum,
you might look at the aims of Soros or Gates and call them laudable.
And often many of them are,
but a world where a select few decide what's good for the rest of the world,
basically amounts to a benevolent oligarchy. And it's not a shadowy cabal.
It's just kind of how modern philanthropy works.
A ton of non-profit activity nowadays is directed in some part by grants,
from huge organizations like the Rockefeller foundation, the Gates foundation,
the Koch foundation,
and also corporate donors looking for good PR companies like MasterCard or
Starbucks are more than eager to shell out millions of dollars to charitable
causes. And Hey, what's wrong with doing a good deed?
The problem like we saw with malaria is that money often has implicit or
explicit strings attached.
The countless health researchers funded by the Gates foundation might for
instance,
feel less inclined to criticize the foundation's policies or its corporate
benefactors as sociologists Lindsay McGaughey notes.
The fact that the Gates is often funded initiatives that many people approve of
should not insulate them from criticism and to date that's exactly what has
happened. Gaping silence,
the autocratic influence on the who is just one example.
We could also consider what it means for global health policy to enforce this
top down model, consider Gates mission to eradicate polio a seriously cool idea.
But the thing is polio has already been combated so well that it doesn't even
hit the top 10 list of things.
People in rural villages are worried about killing them. Donald Henderson,
who led the,
who successful effort to eradicate smallpox is noted that polio vaccines have
come at the expense of other more urgent vaccinations, Henderson accounts,
interactions with villagers who questioned,
why they're being inoculated for polio instead of the much more urgent and
deadly problem of measles.
So is bill Gates doing apparently noble things in all the wrong ways, maybe,
but his undue influence hasn't merely refocused public health priorities at the
highest level. It's also led to a lot of other far shadier policies.
James Love the director of knowledge,
ecology international argues that Gates uses his philanthropy to push a
pro-patent agenda for pharmaceutical drugs,
even in countries that are too poor to afford many patented drugs.
It's a position widely criticized by the public health world.
If drug companies had a little more leeway to produce generic versions of
life-saving drugs,
they would be able to make a dent in the millions of annual deaths from
treatable diseases.
And while bill Gates recently publicly argued that a COVID 19 vaccine needs to
go to those who need it the most, rather than the highest bidder.
If we just let drugs and vaccines go to the highest bidders instead of
to the people in the places where they're most needed, we'll have a longer,
more than just deadly or pandemic. Yes.
Zero interest in tweaking patent laws against his own interest because he built
his entire fortune and continues to grow it with intellectual property laws that
protect Microsoft's profits.
McGaughey writes that his opposition may have single handedly forded efforts to
open pharmaceutical markets to more generic competition.
But there's more McGaughey quotes, NGO director, James Love,
who explains that the Gates foundation funds most of the journalism on this
topic. And they have been hardline advocates for strong patent protection.
Since the 1990s, making an open discussion on the issue, even more difficult,
the influence of donors on the scientific community.
Isn't just limited to the Gates foundation.
McGaughey tells the story of David Healey,
a psychiatrist who was offered a job by the university of Toronto in 2000,
he then gave a talk discussing the limitations of clinical drug trials and
revealing rare side effects in Woking.
The example of Prozac turns out Prozac's manufacturer.
Eli Lilly is a major donor to the university of Toronto and provided over half
the funding to the department.
Healey was supposed to run his job offer was retracted a few weeks later,
if one cares about free and open academic debate,
one has to ask what kind of debate gets swamped based on pressure from donors.
And here's the frustrating thing about conspiracy theorist who see in the
shadows cabals of pharmaceutical reps, attempting mass mind control.
If they turn on a lights, it's just the regular old free market,
which brings us back to ID 2020.
It's worth noting that the stated goal of ID 2020 is to create a digital
identity for people that they individually owned.
They're not proposing some gross centralized surveillance system. The truth,
the real conspiracy, if you will, is far more boring.
They're building infrastructure.
If you're a multinational corporation like Accenture or Microsoft,
a big impediment to doing business is lack of infrastructure in the developing
world.
Microsoft can't sell X-Box is if cities don't have electricity or internet,
Accenture can help companies run data driven ads. If there's no data to mine.
And here is the other quote, unquote,
conspiracy of a ton of corporate philanthropy.
It's just a tax-free way to build the infrastructure. Your company needs say,
you're a mining company looking to extract minerals in a remote part of Africa.
You need to transport supplies in and minerals out, but there's no road.
You could just pay for it. And Mark it as an expense,
or you could work through some charity.
You get a grant from the government to improve infrastructure and get the same
road built for practically free. This is just a made up example,
but there's plenty of real ones that McGaughey details where government loans
for charitable causes just act like venture capital on a risky new business
venture. Take Vodafone a company worth over 80 billion pounds in 2011,
which received 1 million in grants from the British government to launch a
mobile payment system in parts of Africa,
the system that would go on to become highly profitable for Vodafone and their
subsidiaries McGaughey writes while most people would agree that better mobile
access and services in the developing regions is a positive development.
Many would also suggest that Vodafone should incur it's own business cost.
Seeing as the company and its shareholders have full entitlement to all profits
minus taxes, a similar example lies in micro finance.
Very small loans meant to help people lift themselves out of poverty.
After raising billions of dollars in grants, contributions and government aid,
the real winners of the system are Western investors who reap billions in
profits from loans with incredibly high interest rates. In this case,
governments are subsidizing the risks companies take as they build up the
corporate and physical infrastructure to see if they can make a buck.
And with partners like MasterCard, Accenture, and Microsoft,
it's not hard to see why this might be an added bonus for donating to something
like ID 2020 after all digital IDs would function as well.
Digital infrastructure laying the groundwork for all kinds of business to be
conducted. Even if a person is in control of their ID,
it would allow them to willingly give up their information to apply for a credit
card or a micro loan,
or to sign away their privacy willingly and some gargantuan terms of service.
And from there, MasterCard can sell that information to advertisers.
And I want to be careful here because this is the one claim I'm making that
speculative, but I don't think it's a stretch to say somewhere down the line,
there will be a disagreement in how ID 2020 operates.
Let's say over a privacy concern.
When push comes to shove the people writing the checks,
not you or I or anyone using a digital ID in Afghanistan,
we'll get to decide which side wins. Unlike a conspiracy theorist,
I fully acknowledge that they might actually establish meaningful privacy
protection.
And I also know that plenty of organizations involved in ID 2020 really do just
want a better way to provide healthcare to people like the Gates funded Gavi.
There's also the argument that even if MasterCard is itching to sell data,
Hey, at least all that greed might end up helping some people.
But one thing we do know philanthropy can be incredibly profitable journalists,
Tim Schwab notes,
that the Gates foundation has sent millions of charitable contributions to
for-profit companies.
Some of which the foundation owns stocks or bonds in companies like Merck,
Eli Lilly,
and Pfizer Schwab also notes that despite pledging to give away millions of
dollars, bill Gates, personal net worth continues to grow. In 2006,
he was worth 50 billion.
Today he's worth 118 billion and all Gates hasn't profited directly
from his foundation.
It's clear promotes policies that protect his own financial interests.
Of course, the obvious answer to all of this is it's his money.
He can do what he wants and yes, this is true, but it's worth noting.
He doesn't have to pay taxes and all those charitable donations, you may say,
this is a good thing. If I want to donate $50 to my church,
which I won't be taxed on,
isn't that a freer and more democratic form of giving than whatever the
government decides to do with my taxes. And yes,
there's a certain allure to millions of people freely choosing what causes their
money goes to before uncle Sam gets his grubby paws on it.
But with someone like Gates,
a single man has withheld billions of dollars in government revenue and
dispersed it according to his own. Sure.
You might not like where your tax dollars are going to,
but at least elected officials can be held accountable when they allocate $20
million to research CyBorD murder dolphins.
Or maybe we love that idea because that sounds super cool and real like everyone
involved again, democracy.
Now you won't hear stuff like this from the conspiracy sphere of the internet,
you do. It might be a brief footnote in some bigger evil or playing. Yeah,
but that's just the problem. We don't live in a crazy or Welly in dystopia.
We live in a very boring and aside from eroding trust science or causing measles
outbreaks, this is big threat from.
Conspiracy theories. People waste their powers of skepticism chasing Phantoms,
instead of scrutinizing the very flawed reality we live in.
Even if you think bill Gates is an angel that every public health policy
promotes as a home run, that his money is better spent by him than uncle Sam.
You should at least consider the idea as espoused by fame poet, Kanye West,
that no one man should have all that power.
But what do you think wisecrack let us know in the comments,
big thanks to our patrons for supporting the channel and our podcast.
Now that the bill and Melinda Gates foundation will never give us money.
Maybe you should become a patron for $2 a month.
You'll get ad-free access to all of our videos.
And if the comments are any indication,
this is something many of you deeply desire.
And that's just the beginning higher levels can get you access to our patron
only discord where wisecrack writers and hosts like me pop into chat with fans.
If you're a fan of our channel,
you'll really dig everything happening on our Patrion page.
And we have some really amazing things in the works that we'll be adding soon.
So why not get involved now? PS bill, if you're watching this,
we'll make a special tier just for you for $1,000 a month.
We'll let you say you fund media coverage, that vocally criticizes you.
I'll also message you weekly affirmations, like forget the haters.
And at least you're not Mark Zuckerberg and all for less than 1 million of your
net worth,
that's a bargain go to patrion.com/wisecrack and joined today.
And once you do message me on our discord,
so you can tell me how to most efficiently organize my bookshelf.
I'll see you there.
[Inaudible].